ó todos
o algoz tom de voz é sim mas o lado
pessoal aqui quem fala é o dark e eu
estou rouco da voz como vocês podem ver
eu não sei que as pessoas me recordei me
sinto um pouco sem voz mas vamos tentar
gravar é nós estamos aqui pra gravar um
vídeo que vocês vão cumprir há muito
tempo já que este é um jogo do domingo
eu confesso quando comete várias porque
porque dizem dizem os rumores por aí na
internet dizem que este jogo foi
inventado nem fui eu que vou julgar um
jogo de empurra é ver muito divertido
vamos ver em baixo no baixo uma sopa sua
longa história de poeta foi isto
mas o meu passo meu deus seria mesmo a
porta eu acho a um computador pessoal
encontraram em um primeiro corredor de
boba não por do infinito a lei só que
julga por ser avó é preciso agora é
agora toco sentir não é só uma corrida
no molhe oi é muito longo tabu
nenhum eu sou e não ouviu o choro ao
luxo de querer privatizar demos e eu não
vou deixar o hotel el mundo perceber o
que costumo dizer olha aí olha já músico
lhe damos quando a moça não é por isso
iremos que deu a moça vive comigo eu me
sinto muito sortuda
ae o produto para o cai para o médio já
que o seu trabalho já é outro seu
segundo ceni é de ansiedade pois esse
cara não habilita é por aí [ __ ]
encontra uma porta torres novas o
botafogo encontrava chaparro solo é
chave ele pô ele anda mais rápido agora
ficou tudo silencioso o céu estrelado
o rapaz sem cabeça não acontece por
reunião mas já utilizado já entoava a
quinta dimensão jatos turmas do sul e do
sudeste ou agora é agora né
olha isso nos pareceu que um chinês já
nem sequer é o filme não é sobre um
grito ao brasil
eu levo de weakland proeb vou encontrar
agora estou em nota que deu tudo certo e
não sei porque não é possível que o time
jogou com medo schmid eu vou te ajudar
chineses vou tomar um miojo e vou salvar
solo vão salvar o piauí eo prometo 30
mil mas hoje em dia é o que eu chamo a
isso
olha que inclui como assim o lanche e já
falar comigo gastar falar inglês ela
aprendeu a não terminar eu tento ajudar
piauí
eu tô otan possui uma cena em que um
texto
é a culpada gaúcha regularmente como eu
sei que já ouviu de rádio
não vou fugir vou fugir do meu eu fugir
tá comigo tá na caixa d água chateado
porque acho que ela está viva só eu
posso estou aí até ela no méxico não faz
nada porque meu
achei que nunca tive que sair o site na
bits daqui [ __ ]
o provedor consegui [ __ ] plata já vai
encontrar um só passarei todos nós
missionários podem e vai consentir o
teleporte é portanto um sítio cheio de
areia do deserto eu topo de páscoa pra
[ __ ] que sete anós satélite os o
erário sul o time se você ver o que é
hoje o que mais quero até o ricky macho
que é macho
vou falar uma coisa comigo agora já
prendeu um russo chinês mas só mais uma
temporada
acho que sou isso é muito interessante
explosão em rima hora depois só volta à
i
voltei pro mundo real do preto e branco
já joguei eu já sei isto que eu quero
mapa não eu quero lá quando eu quero
buscar o jogo tóxico corre contra vez
foi em outra janela que bonito
adoro ver atirou por da lua
ok vamos lá eu nem sei quem era era que
o homem antes sempre enfrenta é eu
sempre enfrentei
olha vai ser campeão e outras ongs
eu vou salvar novo gestor ao equador
pessoal dos roubos de cargas
a união não iam ficar alheio ou de
repente isso aconteceu quando a quebra
com sua travar e tem um bicho que já a
lua a mesma mulher há que ir não faz
[ __ ] nenhuma que têm fracos óptico um
caminho novo
o juiz atanásio tomar alguma coisa todos
até acho que isto leva me contigo leva
não leva nada fora dessa forma cada vez
me dê investiu que agora tudo se houver
magnífica uma casa com conspiração em
grupo oi não consegui mas vamos ver
não sei nem quero ser mas só eu nem
consigo a filha menor de escutar muito
alto
tá muito tem o seu estilo pois não é
possível disse isto provou isso só e
segundo nosso que era um shopping
pode chorar gritar e obsessivo vai
substituí lá para tirar tartufo já que
estou nada uma discussão em seu site que
está tudo bem
o trabalho já está a passar com o dia ea
hora que um breque papel [ __ ]
já quebrou jessica o eu vou saltar em
cima dela sumir xenium estamos num sítio
muito agradável de se andar
o chão estava em duro mas não importa
vamos mesmo pai vai só olha aí já
começou com código já o solo é jesus
jesus vem até mim e com bom humor brasil
teve uma música de jesus
estou sentindo espaço vai o evangelho
jesus
cheguei até aqui só os gagos um país
insular já atua na área há muito tempo
uma porta que estava assim eu espero que
vocês tenham gostado deste jogo proibido
das 77 não pediu el steel foi uma
recomendação vossa portanto eu jogar já
sabem quando eu falei que favorito a
comer demais jogos não é em sua lan to
lan